did you make any new year's resolution
oh god no no that quit hate that
question next don't understand the
pressure of having to be better than we
are how about we celebrate the person
that has kept us alive this far good job
not dying everybody good job yeah
don't die anymore I mean I look like
life is it perfect no but life isn't
gonna be perfect so you're fat big deal
we're off that everybody's fat that's
the way it goes
we're Americans really fat kind of fat
or trying not to be fat either way
that's coming yeah why would you hate on
it why I mean this is us I mean look
we're adults now we're grownups this is
what we ended up looking like you don't
have the body of an Olympic athlete well
you're not an Olympic athlete you're
done from sales I've got a badass you
are khakis you hike them up when you
walk like you calm down get better I
have friends in my life that don't eat
bread anymore oh yeah that's a big thing
now I'm not eating bread yeah yeah they
don't eat bread they're gonna lose
three-and-a-half pounds
no one's gonna know I make don't eat
bread why are you even here
notes host with butter in the morning
kill yourself
make some room for people who know how
to live look I know there's pressure I
feel it too there's a lot of people
telling you to do more and lose weight
and be better and all that stuff at all
the gym ads now right in the new year
comes out they always show you the
before and after guy trying to get you
to join the gym I always like the before
guy frankly yeah he looks a little fat
he also looks like he has a box of
doughnuts and a lot of friends
yeah after guy he's got a weird look in
his eye and no looks like he takes his
shirt off when he shouldn't this is the
life guys this is what I like this okay
you